В ефірі «heute journal»
з Ханною Ціммерман та Крістіаном Зіверсом.
Привіт і доброго вечора всім.
Всі фани футболу Німеччини
сьогодні святкують з Франкфуртом.
Франкфурт має на те серйозні причини.
Адже ФК «Айнтрахт» здобув перемогу у Лізі Європи.
Сьогодні ввечері команда прибула додому.
Кадри наживо з місця подій.
На площі Рьомерберг вирують емоції.
Просто зараз команда демонструє кубок
своїм відданим вболівальникам,
яких не зупинила ані нещадна спека, ані грози -
вони таки дочекалися переможців.
Згодом до нас приєднається репортер з місця подій.
Президент ФК «Айнтрахт» Петер Фішер зізнався:
«Здобути Кубок Європи
в тисячу разів краще, ніж секс»
І доповнює:
«А все тому, що виграти цей кубок - велика рідкість»
Справді, востаннє «Айнтрахт» тріумфував
42 роки тому в Кубку УЄФА 1980 року.
Це спортивний і фінансовий прорив
для клубу з довгою історією,
що підвищує престиж Бундесліги.
До святкування перемоги
доєдналися не тільки жителі землі Гессен.
Репортаж Петера Тайсена, ZDF Франкфурт.
Визначний момент,
на який з нетерпінням чекав ФК «Айнтрахт».
Після довгих 42 років вони знову здобувають кубок.
Капітан і тренер урочисто заносять його до
ратуші Франкфурта-на-Майні.
Коли Рафаель Борре забиває вирішальне пенальті,
яке забезпечує перемогу -
ніхто не зміг стримати емоцій:
ані гравці на стадіоні у Севільї,
ані 50 000 глядачів публічного показу матчу
на франкфуртському стадіоні Вальдштадіон.
Вночі центр Франкфурта став
місцем грандіозних святкувань.
Багато хто з них сьогодні так і не заснув,
а займав собі місце на площі Рьомерберг.
А все щоб зустріти героїв Кубка Європи.
Та я ледь серцевий напад не отримала - все ж
ми виграли! Тому ми сьогодні тут.
Клас! Матч захоплює подих з першої і
до останньої хвилини.
Супер, це найкраще, що я коли-небудь відчував.
Не віриться, ми завоювали Кубок Європи.
Без чверті шоста переможці Ліги Європи
приземлилися в аеропорті Франкфурта.
Тренер і капітан з кубком вагою 15 кілограмів.
Колона автомобілів повільно рухається
до центру міста,
їх зустрічають тисячі фанатів.
Навіть сильна гроза не може зіпсувати
настрій ﻿вірних шанувальників,
що зібралися на площі Рьомерберг.
Ураааааа!
*співають*
Тільки на площі Рьомерберг співають і кричать
12 000 горлянок.
Скільки всього вболівальників у місті -
точно не знає ніхто.
100 або 200 тисяч.
Їхні святкування тривають
довше та інтенсивніше, ніж заплановано.
Що, як бачимо, нікому не заважає.
Переможці з кубком в руках нарешті виходять
до своїх шанувальників.
Святкування у Франкфурті - тільки-но почалося.
Голкіпер Кевін Трапп переконаний: «Ми всі герої,
без підтримки ми точно не перемогли б.
Це наша спільна перемога.»
І це правда.
Маркус Вользіфер наживо
з площі Рьомерберг у Франкфурті.
«﻿Це наша спільна перемога.» -
Чи відчувається це зараз?
Безперечно, таку спільноту не зустріти ані деінде
в Німеччині, ані в цілій Європі.
Тисячі шанувальників, приблизно 13 тисяч,
це максимум, який вміщає площа.
О 21:35 команда вийшла на балкон.
І в той момент вигуки захоплення стали ще гучніші.
На стадіоні вже було досить гучно,
але цей факт перемоги після 42 років
настільки надихнув вболівальників «Айнтрахт», що
святкування, певно, триватиме всю ніч.
Ми вражені їхньою відданістю.
Сьогодні була сильна гроза,
але вони вистояли й все заради цієї команди,
на цьому балконі.
Дякую, Маркусе. Бажаємо гарно
відсвяткувати перемогу.
Канцлер Німеччини також привітав «Айнтрахт»:
«Ми радіємо з вами перемозі в Лізі Європи!»
Та, безсумнівно, важливішим є те,
що канцлер Шольц сказав сьогодні у Бундестазі:
«Ми нікого не залишимо в біді».
Це можна сприйняти як обіцянку
передусім для людей з низьким рівнем доходів.
Держава пом'якшить вплив
зростаючих внаслідок війни в Україні цін.
Про конкретний план дій наразі мови не було.
Війна була сьогодні центральною темою
урядової заяви канцлера,
темою дебатів у великій пленарній залі та
у залах засідань парламенту,
які не знаходяться у фокусі інтересу громадськості.
Але саме в цих залах тема війни
обговорюється найгарячіше.
Деталі розповість Андреас Кюнаст.
Я вже близько 75 днів перебуваю у лікарні.
Анна Полонська хоче знову стати на ноги,
хоче жити й розповідати свою історію.
Про те, як вона, її чоловік і собака намагалися
виїхати з Бучі.
Сповнені страхом і надією на хоча б дрібку удачі,
яка здатна змінити все.
Коли, наприклад, кілька автомобілів
виїжджали з міста,
деякі з них обстрілювали, а деяких - ні.
Це лотерея.
Жахлива і жорстока.
Анна з лікарняної палати під'єдналася
до кімнати 51.14 Бундестагу.
На Zoom-конференції вона розповідає,
як росіяни обстріляли її автівку.
Антон помер миттєво.
Її ненароджену дитину, хлопчика,
вона втратила пізніше.
Німецько-українська депутатська група запитує,
чи має Анна послання до Німеччини.
Відповідь очікувана.
Я, безумовно, не маю професійних навичок у цій сфері.
Я просто вчителька.
Але, щоб завершити війну, Україні життєво
необхідні боєприпаси та спорядження.
П'ять годин раніше та п'ять поверхів нижче
канцлер ФРН висловився:
факт, що Україна просить зброю в Німеччини,
викликає суперечки.
Олаф Шольц говоритиме також про дискусії
у виборчому окрузі,
про листи громадян, для яких така підтримка
заходить надто далеко.
Я хочу абсолютно точно наголосити,
що немає ескалації в тому, щоб допомагати
в обороні країні, на яку жорстоко напали.
Шольц має рацію - говорить лідер опозиції.
Та от тільки те, що каже Шольц не відповідає
тому, що він робить.
Канцлер грає в подвійну гру.
Правда ж полягає в тому, що за останні кілька тижнів
Німеччина не надала жодного озброєння.
Ми ж маємо доступ до документів.
Фактично нічого не постачають.
На думку Мерца, відповідальність за це несе міністерка оборони,
на звільненні якої він наполягає.
Та поки Союз CDU/CSU звинувачує Шольца та його партію SPD
у недостатній підтримці Україні,
для Лівих і AfD її і так забагато.
Хто їздить до Києва, той нехай навідається також
до Москви, щоб налагодити комунікацію.
Будь ласка, обирайте шлях розуму.
Щиро дякую.
Розмови з Москвою,
переговори з путінським режимом.
Для Анни Полонської навіть думка
про це нестерпна.
Мій чоловік загинув, не тільки мій.
Там багато людей.
І за ці злочини Росія повинна нести відповідальність.
Ганна Полонська знову хоче жити,
хоче знову стати на ноги, як і її країна.
І для цього обом потрібна допомога.
Від Лазурового берега до України досить далеко.
А визнані зірки та молоді «зірочки» кінематографу в Каннах,
що зайняті шампанським, устрицями та червоною доріжкою -
й зовсім неначе з іншої реальності.
Та все ж найголовніший кінофестиваль у світі
не лишається осторонь
війни у Східній Європі.
Ще й тому, що там зіштовхуються один з одним
українські та російські фільми.
Українські й російські режисери.
Наразі прийшла черга Канн дискутувати про те,
на що й ми повинні дати відповідь.
Про війну і культуру, бойкот і толерантність.
Репортаж Сабіни Шульц.
Загарбницька війна Путіна не оминула й
кінофестиваль у Каннах.
Відбудеться показ 4-х українських фільмів,
проте саме російський фільм
одразу ж стає причиною для суперечок.
Принаймні присутність Кирила Серебреннікова -
всесвітньо відомого
російського режисера театру і кіно.
Вільний дух, який у власній країні під прицілом.
Путінський режим обвинувачує його у нібито розкраданні бюджетних коштів,
виділених його проєкту «Сьома студія».
Арешт, суди, роки домашнього арешту,
заборона на виїзд.
Його Каннські прем'єри завжди були
акціями протесту,
але він ніколи не міг приїхати до Канн.
Тільки на початку цього року
йому вдалося покинути свою країну,
відтоді Кирило живе в Берліні й вперше в Каннах.
Та не всі цьому раді.
Ми закликаємо фестиваль
завершити культурну співпрацю з Росією
та з усіма російськими артистами та режисерами.
Допоки Росія не відійде з території України
та не понесе відповідальність за всі скоєні
воєнні злочини.
Це означає: жодних прем'єр російських фільмів,
жодних російських режисерів.
Все частіше лунає заклик до культурного бойкоту.
Але тоді під ударом будуть і ті,
хто і так страждає від путінських репресій.
Фестиваль має чітку позицію:
прихильники російської влади
не допускаються до фестивалю.
Але це не стосується тих російських
митців та журналістів,
які покинули країну.
Кирило Серебренніков вважає:
якщо б він не покинув Росію,
то був би причетним до війни.
Комунікація чи покарання для всіх?
Це актуальне питання цьогоріч в Каннах.
Мій фільм - це незалежний російський фільм,
без державних грошей.
Усі, хто причетний до створення цього фільму,
виступають категорично проти війни.
Кожен фільм, кожна форма мистецтва,
театральні постановки - це проголошення
цінності життя.
А отже повна протилежність цій війні.
Війна не оминула Канни.
Документальний фільм «Маріуполіс 2»
показує руйнування
і страждання людей в Маріуполі.
Режисер фільму - Мантас Кведаравічюс.
На початку квітня під час знімального процесу
його було вбито російською армією.
Його наречена, українка Ганна Білоброва,
зберегла відзнятий матеріал та змонтувала фільм.
Ми хочемо вшанувати його життя
та режисерську спадщину.
Надзвичайно зворушливий момент,
ні на що не схожа прем'єра в Каннах,
у якій відобразилися актуальні події у світі.
Дискусії точаться не лише в кінематографії.
Так, постало питання, чи варто виключати з
програм музичних фестивалів твори Чайковського?
Ми повернемося до цього питання згодом.
Більше новин розповість Ханна.
Дякую. І почнемо ми з новин із півночі Німеччини:
у Шлезвіг-Гольштейні знято
питання «ямайської коаліції».
Це результат попередніх
переговорів CDU, партії Зелених та FDP.
У своєму офіційному коментарі Зелені повідомили,
що переговори закінчилися саме таким рішенням,
оскільки усі учасники переговорчого процесу мали
принципово різні погляди на коаліцію,
а отже такий союз не зміг би бути
ефективним та суспільно корисним.
Відомо, що створення «ямайської коаліції»
підтримував прем'єр-міністр Гюнтер,
незважаючи на те, що CDU вдалося б
отримати урядову більшість
також разом лише із FDP або ж партією Зелених.
Після подання заявки на вступ до НАТО
Фінляндією та Швецією,
настав час почути офіційну позицію альянсу.
Туреччина все ще не підтримує цю ініціативу.
Генеральний секретар НАТО Єнс Столтенберг заявив,
що члени Альянсу обговорять побоювання, озвучені
турецькою стороною. Він очікує на швидке рішення.
Президент США Байден зустрівся
сьогодні у Вашингтоні
з прем'єр-міністеркою Швеції
та президентом Фінляндії.
Він висловив свою підтримку в прагненні
країн до вступу в НАТО.
На сьогоднішній зустрічі міністрів фінансів
країн G7 у Кенігсвінтері
йшлося про новий пакет фінансової﻿
допомоги для України.
В найближчі 3 місяці Україна потребує
13 мільярдів євро для того,
щоб покрити усі витрати державного бюджету.
Німеччина планує виділити 1 мільярд євро.
Очікується, що внесок США становитиме
близько 7,5 мільярда.
Крім того, кілька годин тому Сенат США
ухвалив черговий пакет допомоги для України,
сума якого становить 40 мільярдів доларів.
Герхарда Шредера позбавили всіх привілеїв
як колишнього канцлера Німеччини.
Таке рішення ухвалив сьогодні
бюджетний комітет німецького парламенту.
Рішення торкнеться, зокрема,
офісу Шредера та його співробітників.
Причиною такого кроку називають те, що Шредер
більше не виконує жодних обов'язків,
пов'язаних із його колишньою посадою.
Водночас парламент Європейського Союзу
підтримав рішення про внесення Шредера до
санкційного списку ЄС через зв'язки ексканцлера
з російськими компаніями.
Якщо рішення все ж ухвалять,
ЄС зможе заморозити активи Шредера.
Бундестаг планує ухвалити низку важливих законів
на сьогоднішньому нічному засіданні.
Зокрема, йдеться про квиток вартістю 9 євро,
який має увійти до обігу вже з 1 червня.
Також Бундестаг ухвалив значне скорочення
санкцій для безробітних громадян,
що отримують допомогу Hartz-IV.
Лише після повторного сповіщення про порушення,
сума пільг може бути зменшеною.
Крім того, парламент подовшив дію пільг,
пов'язаних з пандемією коронавірусу.
Так, і цьогоріч при сплаті податків
може діяти знижка за дні роботи з дому.
Також Бундестаг ухвалив бонус
в розмірі 2500 євро для медиків.
В одній зі шкіл Бремергафена
вранці пролунали постріли.
Одна жінка зазнала серйозних поранень.
Близько о 9:15, у той час,
коли в закладі тривали іспити,
21-річний чоловік з самострілом та
газовим пістолетом увійшов до гімназії.
Імовірного злочинця було затримано.
Мотиви злочину наразі не відомі.
Заарештований відмовляється
співпрацювати зі слідчими.
Грім, блискавки, темне небо - саме така погода
очікується сьогодні ввечері в деяких
регіонах Німеччини, зокрема, на заході країни.
Ще вдень від Метеорологічної
служби Німеччини находили попередження
п﻿ро сильні грозові дощі та бурі
у Північному Рейні-Вестфалії.
І якщо більшість з нас після таких попереджень
сподівається, що все обійдеться,
то жителі Арської долини сприймають
таку інформацію абсолютно інакше.
Вони не за чутками знають, чим такі
попередження можуть скінчитися,
коли гинуть люди
та втрачаються засоби до існування.
Усе це вони пережили менше року тому.
Далі - Юлія Шротер.
Бампер до бампера -
машини стоять у заторах до промислової бази
в Бад-Ноєнар-Арвайлері з 7 ранку.
Такий попит тут на мішки з піском.
Проте адміністрацію закладу
цей ажіотаж вже не дивує.
Після жахливих наслідків попередньої негоди
цілком зрозуміло, що люди бояться та панікують,
тому причина заторів очевидна, ми знаємо,
що саме їм потрібно.
Тут, на місцевій базі, все працює як майстерно
налагоджений механізм - за принципом «drive-in».
Спершу інформація про видачу фіксується для того,
щоб ніхто не заїжджав по мішки вдруге.
Процес відбувається надзвичайно швидко:
відкрили багажник, поклали мішки.
Приватні господарства отримують 10 мішків,
промислові - 30.
Закрили багажник - готово.
Наповнюють мішки за кілька метрів звідси.
У кожному мішку 10 кг.
Мішки невтомно складають працівники бази та
волонтери з приватної ініціативи «Helfer-Shuttle».
Саша Шпессерт і Йенс Хілман теж активно
долучаються до роботи.
Вже кілька місяців вони допомагають жителям
Арської долини на волонтерських засадах.
Зокрема, власниці місцевої кнайпи,
яка сильно постраждав від повені минулого липня.
Пані позаду мене - власниця закладу.
Вона вже два дні на нервах,
бо вже в понеділок тут обійшлося без втрат.
Уся вулиця була затоплена.
Рятувальники відкачували воду
кількома пожежними машинами.
Власниця не захотіла з нами розмовляти -
занадто боляче згадувати.
Проте наявність мішків із піском у будівлі
все ж трішки заспокоює.
Ми встановимо їх біля обох дверей
сьогодні ввечері або по обіді,
щоб вода не потрапила всередину.
А тут у нас є вентиляція, що веде до підвалу,
останнім часом туди потрапляло багато опадів.
Підвал може затопити під час повені,
але ми цього не допустимо.
Така посилена підготовка до можливої повені
зумовлена сумним досвідом минулого літа,
спогади про який досі живуть у свідомості містян.
Постраждалі розповіли мені кілька історій:
наприклад, сьогодні чоловік їхав на автомийку і
в нього раптово почалася панічна атака,
а поки що усе ж ніби нормально.
Уявіть, що буде відбуватися,
коли в місті знову почнеться повінь.
Думаю, цієї ночі ніхто не зможе спокійно спати.
Повернімося до бази.
Лише за вчорашній день чоловіки відвантажили
4000 мішків із піском.
Сьогодні планують відвантажити
принаймні стільки ж.
Здавалося б, дрібниця, але все ж краще,
ніж просто сидіти в очікуванні негоди.
Увечері в Арській долині знову очікуються зливи.
Мер Бад-Ноєнар-Арвайлера Гвідо Ортен
виступив зі зверненням до громадян,
попередивши їх про можливу негоду та її наслідки.
Він сказав: «Разом ми обов'язково впораємося
з негодою, але я розумію,
що нині ми відчуваємо зовсім інакше.»
Детальніше про погоду - згодом.
Сьогодні Федеральний верховний суд Німеччини
розглядав важливу справу.
Як і завжди, коли порушуються базові права.
Сьогодні мова йшла про базові права тих, хто
працює у сфері охорони здоров’я та медичного догляду.
Чи обов’язкове для них
щеплення проти коронавірусу?
Конституційний суд впевнений, що так.
Це рішення має покласти край
довгим та запеклим суперечкам.
Принаймні, юридичним. На практиці, рішення
про обов'язкову вакцинацію медпрацівників
сприйняли набагато стриманіше, аніж очікувалось.
Деталі в сюжеті Крістіана фон Рехенберга.
Масаж йде на користь не лише пацієнтці -
принаймні, відволікає пані Паулі від інших турбот.
Пані Паулі - соціальний працівник.
Вона, однією з перших у Німеччині, отримала
лист від департаменту охорони здоров’я,
у якому йшлося про те, що протягом наступних
14 днів вона повинна надати документ
про вакцинацію ﻿або висновок лікаря про те,
що вона перехворіла на коронавірус.
Інакше їй загрожує штраф у розмірі 2500 євро.
Я відчуваю сильний тиск.
І, звісно ж, у мене
теж є певні екзистенційні страхи.
Пані Паулі боїться вакцинуватися.
Склалася доволі непроста ситуація,
оскільки вона працювала
в будинку для літніх людей імені Святої Гедвіги
у Віттенбурзі
та мала постійний тісний контакт з людьми похилого
віку, які, до того ж, мали супутні захворювання.
Для них коронавірус може бути
смертельно небезпечною хворобою.
Щеплення для них теж менш ефективні.
Водночас, вони залежать від догляду та турботи
сторонніх, тобто працівників закладу.
Тому держава має докладати максимум зусиль
для їхнього захисту,
що і доводить сьогоднішнє рішення
Федерального конституційного суду.
Високий ризик для здоров’я літніх людей,
який несе коронавірус, компенсується
значно нижчим ризиком ускладнень від вакцинації
для осіб, які доглядають за ними.
Міністр охорони здоров'я підсумував:
«Саме на таке рішення я очікував.
Але я хочу скористатися можливістю та
подякувати всім закладам, що підтримали
рішення про обов’язкову вакцинацію.
Це велике досягнення».
Насправді ж, не все так однозначно.
адміністрації медичних закладів звернулися
до свого персоналу поки з проханням, не вимогою.
Проте, у Німеччині лише невелика частина осіб,
які доглядають за хворими, не вакциновані.
Як показала вибіркова перевірка ZDF,
у Шлезвіг-Гольштейні лише 3% медпрацівників
не вакциновано,
у Північному Рейні-Вестфалії - майже 10%.
Винятком стала лише Саксонія з більш ніж 30%.
Після закріплення обов’язкової вакцинації
для працівників сфери догляду на рівні закону
наприкінці минулого року,
влада стала побоюватися колапсу.
Прецеденти мали місце,
однак суттєво менше, ніж очікувалось.
Відмова каратиметься штрафом.
Поки що ми утримаємося від звільнень чи
заборон займатися професійною діяльністю надалі.
Ми не можемо собі цього дозволити,
адже нам бракуватиме кваліфікованих кадрів,
владі це також відомо.
Департамент охорони здоров’я перевіряє
фактично кожен зареєстрований випадок.
Розгляд може тривати певний час - таким чином
доглядальниці зможуть продовжуватимуть працювати,
вакцинуватися
або ж шукати альтернативи
зі своїми роботодавцями,
наприклад, перейти до іншого відділення
або збільшити кількість захисного одягу.
Пані Паулі в непростому становищі.
Працюючи тут, ви не зможете
уникнути прямого контакту з пацієнтами.
На жаль, це просто неможливо.
І я не можу запропонувати іншої роботи
або іншого місця роботи.
Незважаючи на те, що керівництво не має змоги
запропонувати альтернативу, пані Паулі відпускають
дуже не охоче,
адже такі професіонали зараз на вагу золота.
Директору не хочеться втрачати пані Паулі.
Я не зміню свого рішення,
і тому, можливо, втрачу роботу.
Незважаючи на те, що я всім серцем люблю
цей заклад і цих людей.
Значний період мого життя минув саме тут.
Пані Паулі подала на апеляцію.
Довга процедура могла б справді
допомогти і їй і закладу,
адже наприкінці року
закон про обов'язкову вакцинацію втрачає силу.
А зараз Анна розповість нам про іншу,
не менш важливу професію.
Відбувся розгляд колективних трудових спорів,
на якому вирішувалася доля
330 000 працівників
дитячих садків та інших соціальних закладів.
Переговори закінчилися,
і, здається, Об'єднання німецьких профспілок Ver.di
цілком задоволено результатом.
Однак є одне але, чи не так, Валері?
Так, важливою умовою працівників є
зменшення навантаження.
Профспілки роками вимагають цього.
Тепер працівники нарешті зможуть
отримати більше вільного часу.
Але загалом картина не змінилася,
кваліфікованих кадрів бракує,
а коли у працівників збільшиться кількість вихідних,
хтось все ж матиме виконувати роботу.
Тож, ми ще побачимо, чи достатньо нових обіцянок
для того, щоб зробити роботу привабливішою,
утримувати працівників та залучати нових фахівців.
Нарешті фахівці, що працюють в дитячих садках та
інших соціальних закладах,
домоглися надбавки та додаткових вихідних днів.
Отже, ухвалене рішення
передбачає 2 додаткових вихідних,
і ще два опційних вихідних за власний рахунок.
З липня педагоги і соціальні працівники
отримуватимуть підвищену зарплату:
додаткові 130 і 180 євро відповідно.
До того ж розмір надбавки за вислугу років зросте.
Підвищення зарплат відбувається швидше,
ніж це було раніше.
Нові зарплати вже погоджують з тарифними ставками
працівників державної служби.
За планами Об'єднання німецьких профспілок ver.di
члени профспілки вже до червня мають проголосувати
за погоджені рішення,
але найімовірніше, що договір підпишуть.
Наступні перемовини про тарифні ставки
працівників держслужби
відбудуться в січні.
Отож, працівники муніципальних установ
у соціальній і освітній сферах
можуть сподіватися на подальші покращення.
Дякую! Валері Галлер з Франкфурта.
За даними дослідження фонду «Allbright Stiftung»,
топменеджмент великих німецьких компаній -
сфера впливу чоловіків.
Сімейні підприємства
показали особливо невтішні результати:
на керівних посадах
100 найбільших сімейних компаній
частка жінок становила 8,3%.
У найпотужніших компаніях зі списку
Німецької фондової біржі DAX
частка жінок майже вдвічі більша - 14,3%.
Дослідження фонду «Allbright Stiftung» демонструють,
що акціонерні компанії, які грають на біржах,
систематично беруть на роботу жінок,
в той час як сімейні підприємства цього не роблять.
Метеорологічна служба Німеччини оприлюднила
офіційне штормове попередження
про сильні, часом дуже сильні грози.
Ніко Ковач повертається до Бундесліги
і стане новим тренером «Вольфсбурга».
Як повідомляють ЗМІ, Ковач відразу ж
зможе виконувати обов'язки тренера замість
Флоріана Кофельда, з яким клуб у неділю
несподівано припинив співпрацю.
Ніко Ковач прийшов у «Вольфсбург»
з посади тренера ФК «Монако».
У 2019 році Ковачу як головному тренеру ФК «Баварія»
вдалося привести клуб до подвійної перемоги:
на Чемпіонаті Німеччини та у Кубку Німеччини з футболу.
Помер Евангелос Одіссеас Папатанасіу.
Це ім’я навряд чи вам щось скаже,
але тільки-но ви почуєте вічну мелодію,
яку він створив,
то відразу ж все зрозумієте.
Вангеліс з Афін, один з перших авторів і виконавців
електронної музики,
здобув всесвітню популярність завдяки відомим кінохітам
і отримав Оскар за цю мелодію
з кінокартини «Вогняні колісниці».
Він писав музику для балетних постановок,
чемпіонатів світу з футболу і Олімпійських ігор.
«Моя музика не намагається викликати емоції,
як-от радість чи біль.
Я працюю для певного моменту,
щоб супроводжувати зображення.»
Ця мелодія пробуджує тисячі образів у нашій голові,
але тепер також і смуток за тим,
хто ніколи не прагнув слави і розголосу,
а жив музикою.
Вангелісу було 79 років.
Таким був наш світ цього четверга.
Відразу ж після новин радимо подивитися
політичне ток-шоу з Майбріт Ілльнер
на тему «Війна в Україні ― чого хоче досягти Захід?»
А близько 00:30 - випуск «heute journal up:date»
з Назан Гьокдемір.
Приємного вечора, до побачення.
Добрий вечір. А зараз - про погоду,
яка досить нестійка, і от що відбувається.
Тривалий грозовий фронт пройшов сьогодні
по обіді по всій Німеччині
і наразі сягнув Балтійського моря.
Грози з градом посилюються і на півночі Баварії.
Така ситуація зберігатиметься надалі,
а потім циклон з грозами відійде,
проходячи над Балтійським морем.
Найсильніші грози очікуємо вже завтра.
Після того, як грози пройдуть на півночі Баварії,
їхня ймовірність зросте на заході,
як-от в Рейнланд-Пфальці.
Завтра вранці грози пройдуть
також і в центрі країни.
В інших областях завтра вранці приємна
і суха погода.
Але вже вдень утвориться велика небезпечна зона
у всій центральній полосі,
тому попереджаємо про сильний дощ
з понад 40 мл опадів за дуже короткий час,
що може привести до локальних паводків.
Очікується град і штормовий вітер,
зберігається небезпека виникнення торнадо.
Негода розпочнеться в обід на заході,
передусім у Північному Рейні-Вестфалії, але увечері
зачепить Саксонію, Бранденбург і Саксонію-Ангальт.
Бережіть себе!